[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bélgica es el país de los mejillones con
patatas fritas las cervezas artesanales
y uno de los mejores chocolates del
mundo sin embargo amigos en unos años
puede que Bélgica sea más conocida por
ser el narco estado de la Unión Europea
Sí sí me habéis escuchado bien su Puerto
marítimo más importante el de amberes se
ha convertido en la mayor puerta de
entrada de narcóticos ilegales en Europa
las mafias están haciendo de oro
Traficando sustancias como la cocaína y
la metanfetamina y para mantener este
business están dispuestas a todo así que
en visualpolitik nos hemos hecho varias
preguntas Cómo ha llegado Bélgica a
convertirse en algo así como el sueño
europeo de Pablo Escobar Cómo está
afectando todo esto a la vida corriente
de los ciudadanos belgas y lo que es más
importante qué se está haciendo para
combatirlo hoy en visualpolitik vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
amberes el Hub europeo del narco
ubicado en el corazón de Europa el de
amberes es un puerto atípico porque no
está en la costa sino 80 kilómetros
tierra adentro al comienzo del estuario
del río escalda y de hecho está
peculiaridad es precisamente la que
favorece que el puerto de amberes sea el
segundo con mayor tráfico de mercancías
del continente europeo
[Música]
el puerto de amberes cuenta con 50
kilómetros de muelles que están
conectados con el interior del
continente europeo por ferrocarril
carretera vías fluviales y canales en
estos muelles se descargan cada año 11
millones de contenedores En total son
más de 235 millones de toneladas de
mercancías las que anualmente entran en
el viejo continente utilizando este
Puerto el doble que hace apenas 20 años
11 millones de contenedores en una
cuenta rápida estamos hablando de más de
30.000 contenedores cada día y pensad
que el comercio marítimo ofrece al
narcotráfico las mismas ventajas que a
cualquier otra industria con los
contenedores se transportan altos
volúmenes de mercancía a un coste
relativamente Bajo como podéis imaginar
controlar lo que llega en cada uno de
estos contenedores es prácticamente una
Misión Imposible para los 700 agentes de
aduanas que tiene el puerto de amberes
porque las cifras del puerto son
completamente
abrumadoras estos 700 agentes tienen que
supervisar a 60.000 trabajadores entre
estibadores operadores de grúas y el
resto de profesionales del puerto y
claro cómo os podéis imaginar en cestos
tan grandes siempre hay manzanas
podridas
[Música]
El caso es que la corrupción ha
penetrado en el puerto de amberes
Durante los últimos años las mafias han
logrado infiltrar a topos como
trabajadores del puerto de esta forma
tienen la capacidad de indagar quién
puede ser llegado el caso más
susceptible de aceptar un soborno
habitualmente hablamos de bastante
dinero varios miles de euros por
trabajos tan sencillos como facilitar
algo de información y si el trabajador
en cuestión no acepta ser comprado las
mafias siempre pueden tratar de
intimidarlo con amenazas por eso se cree
que la cantidad de personas que trabajan
para las organizaciones criminales en el
puerto es cada vez mayor
[Música]
a través de sus túneles con grandes
escáneres el puerto de amberes
actualmente supervisa uno de cada 200
contenedores Así que podéis imaginaros
Hasta qué punto Tener información sobre
el día a día en el puerto puede llegar a
ser importante los agentes de aduanas
buscan artículos de contrabando
productos falsificados y sobre todo los
polvos blancos procedentes de América
Latina y por supuesto no estamos
hablando de azúcar ni tampoco de sal la
coca se ha convertido en una de las
reinas de la fiesta del puerto de
amberes
precisamente por eso en el punto de mira
de los equipos de aduanas se sitúa de
forma muy especial el comercio con
Sudamérica los narcotraficantes
aprovechan los envíos de fruta fresca
como las bananas y las piñas para
esconder su particular mercancía en su
interior Sí tal cual como lo escucháis y
muchos os preguntaréis Pero por qué la
fruta fresca Bueno pues si lo pensáis se
trata de una de las principales
exportaciones de Sudamérica a Europa por
tanto no Debería ser un cargamento que a
priori pusiera sobre alerta a la aduana
otro detalle muy importante es que
estamos hablando de productos
perecederos lo que hace que las prisas
para que se distribuyan rápidamente por
los mercados sean mucho mayores además
un contenedor de fruta no deja de ser
uno más entre los miles que circulan
cada día por amberes así que las
posibilidades de ocultar los narcóticos
son enormes y el riesgo de ser detectado
es mínimo
[Música]
modelo de negocio de las mafias es
enviar masivamente tantos contenedores
cargados con estupefacientes como les
sea posible son conscientes de que las
aduanas pueden permitirse una pérdida de
entre un 10 y un 20% de la carga una
pérdida así sería letal para la
rentabilidad de cualquier industria no
ocurre Lo mismo para los
narcotraficantes Especialmente los
colombianos para los está convirtiendo
en su principal mercado
una de las claves de este modus operandi
es que el principal beneficio en la
industria de la cocaína no está en la
venta al por menor ni en la producción
no está en el transporte según las
estimaciones que se manejan el margen
del productor de cocaína puede ser de un
150% del coste de producción el margen
de beneficio de la venta al consumidor
sería de un 300%, pero amigos amigas en
el caso del transporte desde su lugar de
origen hasta el mercado final este puede
llegar al 1500% dependiendo al lugar de
Europa que llegue y más de uno se
estaréis preguntando Pero por qué hablas
de Europa y no de otros lugares Pues
bien fundamentalmente es una cuestión de
rentabilidad el precio de la cocaína en
la calle es mayor en Europa que en
Estados Unidos pero esperad un momento
porque hay más motivos
[Música]
Christian vanderware director general de
las aduanas de Bélgica nos explica a
quién le interesa más que las drogas
fluyan hacia Europa en lugar de al
gigante norteamericano y Colombia
invitó
de Colombia en Production Así que la
pregunta es Quiénes están haciendo en
este caso de mexicanos Quiénes son los
intermediarios Pues bien Parece que
fundamentalmente son mafias procedentes
de los balcanes parientes lejanos de los
albaneses que se cruzaron con liam
neeson en venganza estas mafias han
levantado un imperio valorado en miles
de millones de euros han entablado
contacto con los carteles de
latinoamérica y han ampliado las rutas
de envío hacia Europa lo que está
disparando sus ganancias los principales
países donde se produce cocaína para
clientes europeos son Colombia Perú y
Bolivia pero ojo porque el transporte es
diferente
se están empezando a transportar
narcóticos desde lugares que no están
tan manchados por el narcotráfico en el
caso de la cocaína encontrada en Bélgica
la droga está llegando desde Ecuador
sobre todo desde el puerto de
contenedores de Guayaquil os hemos
hablado ya de ello en la tan política el
boletín de América Latina que recibís
los miembros de patreon Sí desde Ecuador
pero también desde surinam la cuestión
es que el tráfico de drogas en amberes
No para de crecer y está atrayendo a
mafias de todo el mundo el crimen
organizado está intentando hacerse con
este mercado algo que está Desatando una
ola de violencia sin precedentes y la
pregunta es cómo está afectando esto a
la buena gente de amberes Pues bien
veámoslo
Skyfall
en 2021 las autoridades belgas
incautaron 90 toneladas de cocaína en el
puerto de amberes prácticamente el 40%
de toda la cocaína incautada en la Unión
Europea para 2022 los números se espera
que hayan sido muy similares y es
posible incluso que se haya cumplido la
previsión de las autoridades belgas y
alcanzar las 100 toneladas encautadas
durante ese año los narcos están usando
amberes como subían entrada a Europa y
las cifras se superan año tras año tal y
como reconoce Florence angelitie de la
aduana
belgad and me like to stop this estos
continuos récords han supuesto un cambio
notable en el tráfico de drogas hacia el
continente europeo tradicionalmente la
cocaína viajaba principalmente desde
Colombia y eran las costas del sur de
Europa las que recibían los cargamentos
sin embargo eso ya ha cambiado hay dos
países del Norte que acaban de superar a
España como los preferidos por los Pablo
Escobar del momento Bélgica y Países
Bajos son ahora los principales hubs de
la cocaína en Europa según europol ahora
bien que en Bélgica hayan aumentado las
incautaciones de cocaína no es algo
caído del cielo es el resultado de 2
años de investigación policial culminada
por la conocida como operación Sky sc
Sky FC es el nombre de una app
canadiense que ofrece un servicio de
mensajería cifrada Por si no lo sabíais
encriptar las comunicaciones es el
primer tema del manual del delincuente
profesional Así que según parece Sky FC
estaba en el top de descargas para los
capos de la cocaína por eso los cuerpos
policiales de varios países se marcaron
como objetivo descifrar esta la
investigación tuvo éxito interceptó mil
millones de mensajes un año después de
la operación Sky ecc los resultados son
espectaculares
operaciones que hay FC 888 sospechosos y
4.500 millones de euros en drogas
incautadas la caída de Sky FC sacó a la
luz una gran red de empresas legítimas
creadas expresamente para importar
drogas de Sudamérica y lavar los
beneficios cosechados también reveló una
verdad amarga Y es que los capos no se
esconden en las grandes mansiones de
Bruselas sino en Villas lujosas de
lugares tan exóticos y lejanos como Así
que es mucho más difícil echarles el
guante
[Música]
sea como sea
4.500 millones de euros no son
calderilla y las mafias no se quedaron
de brazos cruzados respondieron como se
espera de los malos de una película con
una venganza violenta que pone a todos
los belgas bajo amenaza quieren causar
temor y han llegado incluso a intentar
El secuestro de Vincent Van kikenboard
actual ministro de Justicia después de
anunciar un plan de lucha contra el
narcotráfico en amberes el propio Bank
kickenborn no tiene ninguna duda sobre
lo que está pasando en Bélgica y lo
resume todo en una palabra
narcoterrorismo
Y es que lo cierto Es que Bélgica sufrió
en 2022 el peor verano que se izquierda
en cuanto a violencia se refiere
Bruselas yamberes han protagonizado
continuos titulares en los que se
sucedían los tiroteos
incendiosintencionados apuñalamientos e
incluso ataques con granadas a viviendas
y comercios hay una batalla por el
territorio y por controlar el epicentro
de la cocaína de Europa porque lo cierto
Es que una verdad incómoda prevalece a
pesar del éxito de la operación Sky FC
fijaos
el mercado de la cocaína aun siendo
ilegal no escapa de la ley de la oferta
y la demanda a pesar de todas las
toneladas incautadas por las autoridades
Lo cierto es que el precio en la calle
de la cocaína no ha aumentado y se
mantiene estable en torno a los 50 euros
por gramo toda una señal de que la droga
sigue entrando en Europa con suma
facilidad es decir hablamos de un
mercado enormemente lucrativo
las autoridades arrestaron a unas 160
personas en el puerto de amberes en 2021
aún así es una ciudad en la que ya es
tan fácil obtener polvos blancos como
pedirte una pizza a domicilio de todos
modos posiblemente todavía sea muy
pronto para hablar de Bélgica como un
narco estado pero que nadie dude de que
en 10 años podría convertirse en uno si
no logran atajar la tendencia actual Así
que la pregunta por tanto es Qué piensan
hacer las autoridades belgas para frenar
en narcotráfico y ojo porque todo este
tema tiene una lectura política tan
inesperada como sorprendente atentos
[Música]
el flamenco contra Vivaldi
amberes es la ciudad más poblada de
flandes región que alberga un
nacionalismo poderoso encabezado por la
nueva alianza flamenca este partido ha
sido el más votado en las tres últimas
elecciones federales belgas pero
únicamente formó parte del Gobierno
Federal durante una legislatura y ni
siquiera lo lideró lo más habitual es
que forme parte de la oposición y su
líder es Bart de viver alcalde de
amberes Durante los últimos 10 años de
víver es la figura política más
destacada del nacionalismo flamenco y
ahora está aprovechando el estallido
violento vinculado al narcotráfico en
amberes para arremeter contra el
Gobierno Federal belga el formado por la
coalición Vivaldi
Vivaldi es el apodo dado en Bélgica a la
coalición del Gobierno Federal que desde
el año 2020 reúne a representantes de
cuatro familias políticas diferentes el
apodo hace referencia a las cuatro
estaciones del compositor italiano
Antonio Vivaldi digamos que se considera
que el verde de los ecologistas Encarna
la primavera el rojo de los socialistas
el verano el naranja de los
democristianos flamencos el otoño y el
azul de los liberales el invierno
por supuesto los críticos de The beamer
consideran oportunista utilizar el
tráfico de drogas para hacer política
dicho de otra forma ven poco elegante
intentar sacar tajada de un tema tan
delicado Claro que eso corresponde ya a
la interpretación de cada uno lo que no
es menos cierto es que hace años que el
alcalde de amberes declaró la guerra
contra las drogas Y es de los pocos
representantes públicos que se atreven a
hablar de este asunto sin pelos en la
lengua Mirad que la gente no quiere ver
que subraya de Coca está vinculada al
crimen organizado el alcalde de amberes
ha llegado a den que el Gobierno Federal
no está haciendo lo suficiente para
combatir los delitos relacionados con
las drogas porque la élite social
consume drogas también hizo un
llamamiento a la reflexión de la
sociedad al considerar que se ha
normalizado su consumo y reivindicó del
gobierno más recursos para reforzar la
seguridad en el puerto de amberes y más
competencias para que las ciudades y
municipios puedan enfrentarse a la
violencia desatada por los narcos
[Música]
El caso es que the beaver se ha
convertido en el paladín contra el
imperio de los narcos y ojo porque justo
ahora eso puede tener implicaciones
importantes por ejemplo en las últimas
elecciones federales la nueva alianza
flamenca se vio lastrada por la gran
subida de un partido independentista
radical de extrema derecha el blangs que
fue aislado de la política de pactos por
tener un pasado en el que llegó a ser
ilegalizado por racista Pues bien Ahora
the beaver evitar que continúe ese
ascenso en las próximas elecciones y
aquí su campaña antinarcos le puede
venir que ni pintar con federalismo o
nada bardeweber advierte de Cara a las
elecciones de 2024 de vida quiere que el
estado belga se convierta en una
confederación de flandes y valonia para
poder regir la región flamenca de forma
completamente Autónoma y ese nada ya
sabemos lo que significa en la política
belga sin la nueva alianza flamenca y la
ultraderecha independentista de
blazbeland en la ecuación para formar
una coalición de gobierno tiene toda la
pinta de que Bélgica se puede enfrentar
a otra gran crisis política con un
gobierno en funciones que se prolongue
cine día en el tiempo debido a la falta
de acuerdo para formar un gabinete nuevo
tras las elecciones sea como sea queda
tiempo para eso y de momento amberes
tiene problemas más acuciantes problemas
como este la aduana en Bélgica que las
incineradoras ya no pueden seguir el
ritmo
mentira pero las infinadoras de Bélgica
se ven incapaces de acabar con lo que el
fiscal de amberes ha bautizado como la
montaña de cocaína
[Música]
ni las incineradoras tienen capacidad
para quemar tanta cocaína y lo permiten
las restricciones ambientales para la
destrucción de grandes cantidades de
droga todo esto genera preocupaciones de
seguridad a que se teme que las
organizaciones criminales puedan ahora
atacar esos lugares para recuperar
algunas de las toneladas incautadas la
buena noticia es que parece que Vivaldi
está reaccionando en primer lugar porque
el Gobierno Federal se ha movido para
incrementar la capacidad para incinerar
drogas y fundamentalmente porque ha
prometido recursos para luchar contra en
el narcotráfico 16 de septiembre de 2022
el gobierno belga revela un plan para
combatir el crimen organizado Vivaldi ha
prometido 300 millones de euros para un
plan llamado xxl se invertirán en
incorporar más de 100 agentes de aduanas
al puerto de amberes y Añadir cinco
escáneres fijos más cerca de las
terminales del puerto para que al menos
se puedan inspeccionar todos los
cargamentos sospechosos Vivaldi ha
atendido las peticiones de la alcalde de
amberes Y a partir de ahora los
municipios estarán autorizados a ordenar
el cierre de negocios sospechosos de
tener vínculos con las mafias de la
droga hablamos de pizzerías cafeterías o
peluquerías que están siempre vacíos
pero que nunca cierran porque simple y
llanamente sirven para lavar una parte
del dinero de los narcos seguro que
vosotros no vivís en amberes y también
conocéis Algún negocio así aunque solo
sea por ver ozark en Netflix sea como
sea la pregunta ahora es para ti crees
que estas medidas serán suficientes para
frenar el narcotráfico en amberes o
pensáis que las mafias van siempre Un
paso por delante de la policía podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios si el vídeo te ha resultado
interesante Dale al botón de like y no
olvides suscribirte a visualpolitik si
aún no lo has hecho muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]